page lamentable pour un élément
essentiel du patrimoine national selon
l'elysée la détente menacer les chefs
d'état parle de guerre pourquoi une
enquête avec raymond aron mundial
l'argentine triomphe
les hollandais n'ont pas à serrer la
main du général videla bernard hinault
le champion en france un des fans aucun
des favoris du tour qui commence jeudi
là messieurs bonsoir un attentat
écoeurant écoeurant de gratuité
d'ignorance ce qui s'est passé cette
nuit à versailles révoltera tous les
français d'une manière générale tous les
amateurs d'art et d'histoire anonymement
des responsables s'en sont pris à l'une
des plus belles ailes du château de
versailles
l'ale du midi partiellement détruite par
une explosion à 2 heures du matin trois
salles détruites
cet autre touché la galerie des
batailles sinistrés les dizaines de
tableaux et de sculptures ravagé voilà
donc le résultat de ce véritable
désastre
trois fois revendiquer déjà ce qui fait
qu'on ne sait trop sur quelle piste
s'engager deux mouvements mal connue le
groupe ouvrier révolutionnaire et le
groupe contre le chômage internationale
enfin l'ex armée révolutionnaire
bretonne dissoute il ya quatre avec
françois connaît maintenant les images
de cet attentat criminel
l'explosion était provoquée par un engin
de forte puissance placée derrière ce
buste au rez-de-chaussée de l'aide du
midi une brèche de 10 m de diamètre
s'est ouverte dans les plafonds mais
aucun tableau n'a été touché dans la
galerie des batailles dans les salles
consacrées à la période consulat et
empire des banquettes des bustes
dépliants et des torchères ont été
entièrement détruit une dizaine de
tables ont été sérieusement endommagés
la conservation pense pouvoir les
restaurer c'est vraisemblablement dans
la soirée d'hier au cours des dernières
visites que la charge explosive a pu
être dissimulées
les enquêteurs n'excluent pas toutefois
l'hypothèse d'une effraction nocturne
il y avait plusieurs milliers de
personnes dimanche soir à versailles
massés autour du bassin de neptune pour
assister à la grande féerie des eaux
dans le parc du château
mais les fenêtres ont toutes été soufflé
et il n'a pas été possible de déceler la
moindre trace d'effraction
une seule personne mais si c'est d'une
association ou si c'est un particulier
je dois vous dire qu'il est d'une
barbarie sont légales car s'attaquer à
un monument qui n'a pas été touchée
depuis louis xiv par aucun attentat et
en arriver là maintenant tu en fais don
ça lamentable de la part de qui que ce
soit il l'a fait
est ce qu'il ya une défaillance selon
vous de vos services de surveillera du
champ puisque les gardes les gardes de
nuit passée à ce moment là dans la
grille des batailles au dessus peut
m'envoyer et par conséquent l'exfoliant
explosé quand les gardiens de nuit et l
astra dans la salle alors par conséquent
le seuil de sécurité marchait
parfaitement bien ce nom comment voulez
vous qu'un gardien fasse quoi que ce
soit contre 1 contre une bombe digue l'a
bien fait le président de la république
avait inauguré le 16 mai dernier c'était
le sud du château qui abrite le musée
toutes les gloires de la france voulue
par louis-philippe plusieurs toiles
représentent l'épopée napoléonienne
faits militaires campagne mariage
et ça il faudrait aujourd'hui 5 millions
de francs pour restaurer ses peintures
un attentat qui ne pouvait pas être
évité selon le directeur des musées de
france
effectivement on peut toujours dire
devant un attentat de ce type qu'on
aurait dû le prévoir ou qu'on aurait pu
le prévoir nous ne pensons pas une
seconde que devant quelqu'un de décider
qui a décidé de le faire sauter c'est le
mot une partie du château va nous ne
pensons pas qu'une impulsion de prévoir
l temps mais il y aura toujours toujours
une possibilité quelle qu'elle soit
versailles a ouvert ses portes à des
millions et des millions de visiteurs
c'est le troisième monument de france le
plus visité après le musée georges
pompidou et la tour eiffel construit en
124 par louis xiii embellie par louis
xiv et louis 15 c'est l'un des plus
grands chefs-d'oeuvre laissés par les
artistes du xviie et xviiie siècles
demain il faudra peut-être fouiller les
visiteurs comme dans les aéroports pour
éviter qu'un attentat comme celui
d'aujourd'hui ne se reproduise
commentaire du portant le lisais tout à
l'heure c'est un dommage lamentable a
dit monsieur rentes de match creuser un
élément essentiel du patrimoine national
les aujourd'hui d'ailleurs l'association
espace pour demain lance une
souscription internationale pour la
restauration du château toutes les
souscriptions peuvent être envoyés à la
fondation de france compte château de
versailles
ccp paris 3 169 67 rue de lille paris
75007 la coupe du monde maintenant et
bien la coupe du monde c'est fini et
bien fini vous avez assisté hier soir
sur cette chaîne aux alentours de 23h au
point final de cette grande fête du
football
point final en forme d'apothéose pour
les argentins qui révèle ce trophée
depuis 48 ans et qu'ils y préparer
minutieusement dupuis 4 ne boudons pas
le mondial même si le football y fut de
moins bonne qualité que lors des coupes
du monde précédentes mais pensons à la
paix mondiale
les commentaires sont la ville le
général videla a gagné il a cimenté par
la victoire de son équipe
un peuple ne lui fait pas crédit
une technique en tout cas que du bout
des lèvres et qui vous voyez sens de
leur vie
ça joue et puis le général videla c'est
aussi refaire un image à l'étranger une
image un petit peu restaurer alors cela
dit nous ne fermons pas les yeux
des problèmes demeurent et des
infortunés hollandais le lui ont bien
fait comprendre avant même que ne
commence le mondial les hollandais
avaient annoncé que quoi qu'il arrive il
n'irait pas serrer la main
biden voilà pourquoi sur le podium
spécialement dressés pour la cérémonie
la junte grand complet a attendu une
vingtaine de minutes
dès lors aux landais qui ne sont
finalement pas venues assister à la
remise de la coupe du monde non pas
qu'ils aient mal accepté la victoire
simplement il ne voulait pas apporter
leur caution un homme qui bascule
vertement les droits de l'homme
car au delà de toute considération
politique la réalité quotidienne de
l'argentine ce n'est pas uniquement le
football ce sont aussi et surtout les
arrestations arbitraires les tortures
les exécutions sommaires au total 8000
morts quinze mille disparus
dix mille prisonniers politiques selon
les chiffres d'amnesty international les
hollandais qui sont particulièrement
attentifs au respect des droits de
l'homme ont su s'en souvenir pour être
dossier de l'accusation
nous avons bien entendu voulu donner la
parole à la défense alors basta de
l'argentine à paris pour qui le monial
est une réussite
une belle démonstration d' équilibre
politique en argentine le mondial a
démontré qu'elle était l'agent d'une
réelle après tout ces deux légendes
qu'on a voulu le faire sur mon pays nous
avons démontré que ces pays qui vit en
paix qui a eu des problèmes comme
beaucoup d'autres pays dont les besoins
mais que nous sommes entrés devancé la
démonstration d'un peuple qui a
librement a démontré sa joie et le
monter sur le plus grand sur ce qu'on a
dit sur l'antique malheureusement quand
un pays a souffert
l'époque de terrorisme que nous avons
vécue il ya toujours ce problème des
gens qui disparaissent
nous faisons tout ce que nous pouvons
pour retrouver et c'est un des ventes
population de mon gouvernement de
pouvoir le plus vite possible donner de
nouvelles vous pensez qu'il n'y aura
aucune retombée politique aucune
inflexion politique
maintenant que le miel est terminée ni
dans un sens ni dans l'autre
certains ont dit en france que ça peut
provoquer une libéralisation d'autres
ont dit qu'une fois que les témoins
étrangers seront partis au contraire ça
peut être le début d'un serrage de vis
si j'ose dire
donc ça c'est une autre des thèmes que
la campagne anti argentine a posé nous
personnellement nous avons commencé avec
l'appui de tout le pays un pin époque de
récupération nationale quand le pays
était fait tomber très bas avec un
problème politique un problème
économique priverait alors le mondial et
d'une étape circonstancielle que nous
avons tâché de faire le mieux possible
nous avons démontré que nous étions
capables de le faire mais nous allons
continuer à voir à quoi accomplir les
objectifs procès pour que le pays
redevienne il évoque aussi permanente et
sérieuse la politique maintenant avec ce
rendez vous que je vous rappelle un
carte sur table exceptionnelle mercredi
soir jean pierre elkabbach et alain
duhamel recevront jeannette torres
vermeersch 67 ans la veuve de maurice
thorez ancien secrétaire général du pc
ils ont partagé 35 ans d'expérience et
de vie commune elle a décidé de rompre
pour antenne 2 un silence de 10 ans elle
s'exprimera mercredi sur les dissidents
sur la déstalinisation sur l'évolution
du mouvement communiste et nationales et
bien entendu sur le débat qui secoue à
l'heure actuelle le pc c'est donc un
rendez vous que je vous recommande
mercredi donc en compagnie de jeannette
torres vermeersch à 21h25
une petite phrase de michel pinçon le
délégué général de l'udf l'udf est
chargé de préparer un second septennat
pour le président giscard d'estaing
c'est ce qu'il a dit ce matin sur france
inter michèle patron qui par la même
occasion à tirer des leçons des
élections municipales d'aix-en-provence
en faisant observer que si la majorité
gagner c'est parce que l'été unis est
ouverte la plupart des commentateurs
relèvent en effet l'exemple d'aix en
priorité dans ces partielles
à noter aussi que la majorité a
également enlevé au ps la mairie de
wimereux qu'elle a gardé celle de
briançon et celle de flers mais que son
merci mais sans son maire sortant
adverse et qu'elle a perdu celle du
creusot et un siège de conseiller à
soissons oui je crois que il faut une
fois de plus être prudent premièrement
elle est toujours difficile de tirer des
conclusions politiques d'élections
partielles
deuxièmement cela paraît encore plus
difficile de pelé dernières élections
législatives
parce que les résultats vont un peu dans
tous les sens et puis troisièmement les
résultats que vous venez de donner
vous-même confirme bien ces jours-ci
cette impression mais il ya quand même
deux faits saillants le premier donc
c'est aix en provence où la majorité
l'emportent sur les socialistes
la liste majoritaire était conduite par
un jeune avocat radical monsieur doigts
fins qui bat nettement le sénateur maire
sortant socialiste
monsieur six collines par contre alors
il ya le creusot le creusot celle
inverse la liste sortante de gauche
conduite par le socialiste camille
dufour et réélu en améliorant nettement
son score de mars 77 alors on pourrait
apparemment tiré une conclusion c'est le
conclusion c'est celle ci là où la
majorité est divisée elle perd là ou là
la gauche est divisée elle perd là où la
gauche est unie comme au creusot elle
confirme ses victoires mais il faut
quand même se rappeler l'exemple à ses
récents c'était le mois dernier de saint
malo où la gauche l'a été divisée et la
liste conduite par le socialiste
monsieur wauquiez maire sortant l'avait
emporté assez facile ce qu'on peut
retenir aussi c'est une nouvelle faille
dans ce que l'on a appelé lampion
milliards de pertes et de la provence
côte d'azur sociale je crois que c'est
sans doute la leçon qu est la plus nette
et les locales ou régionales
il y a un certain déclin en tout cas un
certain reflux du parti socialiste dans
les bouches du rhône n'est ce reflux
avait déjà été sensiblement des
législatives en 1973 sur un département
qui compte 11 sièges de députés les
socialistes en avait eu quatre et ils en
ont perdu 2 au printemps dernier et
alors cette fédération du parti
socialiste que conduite par gaston
defferre et quand même une des plus
puissantes du parti socialiste alors il
semble que comme d'autres fédérations
issue essentiellement est de la sf noël
soit actuellement en train de connaître
un certain vieillissement le dossier
social maintenant vous sac les salariés
toucheront leur paie de juin c'est la
raison pour laquelle vous rappelle les
ouvriers de l'usiné avait barré la route
nationale 57 dans les vosges
moulinex la situation est assez confuse
après l'évacuation de lusine d'alençon
dans celle de cormelles dans le calvados
un groupe de cadres et non grévistes se
sont introduits par la force dans
l'enceinte de l'usiné occupée afin de
pouvoir travailler un mauvais indice des
prix pour le mois de mai si on s'y
attendait il serait compris dans une
fourchette de 1,2 à 1,4
on en aura une confirmation officielle
demain d'autres chiffres maintenant
des chiffres qui inquiètent de 52
millions d'habitants aujourd'hui la
france passera à 36 millions dans 120
ans si elle conserve le même rythme
démographique et oui la population
française est vieillissante
la natalité est en baisse et le conseil
économique social a décidé de se pencher
sur le dossier
il écoutera demain un rapport de madame
evelyne sullerot un rapport qui met
également en garde contre l'engorgement
de certaines professions notamment dans
l'enseignement il ait eu des enfants
assez nombreux né à partir de 1945 au
lieu de recruter à ce moment là des
instituteurs et les professeurs
on a attendu qu'ils arrivent comme une
vague dans l'enseignement secondaire
donc les professeurs de ce fait sont
très jolies la majorité a moins de 35
ans alors en même temps on devrait
compter on a beaucoup recruté on a
recruté environ 14 les professeurs du
secondaire par an avec des pointes à
venir pendant 20 ans et puis maintenant
on ne devrait compter que sur
l'augmentation des effectifs scolaires
pour pouvoir continuer à recruter alors
un il n'y aura pas départ à la retraite
puisque les professeurs sont très jeunes
et les instituteurs au corpus 60% moins
de 30 ans et 2 il y aura au contraire
baisse des effectifs à cause de la
baisse de natalité puisqu'il faut bien
qu'on en parle
l'espagne de la baisse des naissances
qu'a connue la france depuis 1973
donc parce que plus de débouchés le
renseignement et la corruption qui sont
également tous restent solides débouchés
et le conseil économique et social le
kanji des rapporteurs pour ces questions
pense qu'il faut faire quelque chose
nous proposons tout de même puisque
maintenant nous savons que ça va se
produire c'est inéluctable il faut avoir
donc des prévisions longue et dé
prévention précoce et s'y prendre à
temps mais d'autres professions sont en
effet un effectif très jeune comme ça
avec une pyramide
taj est fier peu de départs à la
retraite le sud l'ingéniérie
l'électronique la chimie etc
cet effort un discours de leonid brejnev
hier à minsk un avertissement sans frais
à jimmy carter pour qu'il ne joue pas la
carte chinoise une réponse de jimmy
carter dans quelques minutes à
l'occasion d'une conférence de presse
il ne se passe pas un jour sans que nous
ayons à vous parler de la détente une
détente bien menacé retour à la guerre
froide simple guerre fraîche ou beaucoup
plus grave encore faut dire que nous
nous interrogeons et que la réponse
n'est pas au bout d'un téléscripteur
pourtant ce soir nous avons décidé de
vous présenter le dossier de la manière
la plus complète possible en essayant de
synthétiser les différents signaux qui
nous arrivent de tout l'univers a
commencé d'abord par les déclarations de
ceux qui mènent le monde c'est l'ennemi
brejnev qui commence depuis prague où il
est allé rencontrer les leaders tchèque
dix ans après le fameux printemps ils
dénoncent ceux qui essayent de torpiller
le processus de la détente et de
retourner sinon à une guerre froide
en tout cas à une guerre fraîche brejnev
parle aussi et surtout de l'afrique de
l'ingérence entre guillemets au zaïre
désormais c'est brejnev qu'il dit si
nous ne sommes pas encore à la guerre
froide la détente n'est plus d'actualité
le 7 juin à annapolis carter répond à
brejnev l'union soviétique peut choisir
la confrontation ou la coopération les
etats unis sont suffisamment prêtes pour
faire face à ces deux situations et il
ajoute la détente doit être
véritablement réciproque
chacun des deux pays doivent faire
preuve de retenue dans les régions
troublées
pendant les périodes difficiles brejnev
répond encore à carter ou plutôt fait
répondre par pravda interposés nous
avons choisi depuis longtemps la
coexistence pacifique
il semble que les dirigeants de
washington n'est pas encore fait leur
choix
il y en a qui veulent revenir à la
guerre froide entre nous et chinois les
américains devront choisir
le maréchal tito cet apôtre du
neutralisme rappelle une guerre mondiale
risque toujours d'éclater car la
politique de force d' ingérence dans les
affaires intérieures d'autrui persiste
et le président tito en appelle aux
etats-unis à l'union soviétique
il est évident dit-il que le monde ne
peut pas ne pourra pas être organisée
par la guerre la guerre s'exclame le
président senghor dans une interview à
notre confrère le figaro la troisième
guerre mondiale
et bien elle a commencé et en afrique et
plus précisément en angola
l'est est attiré par le vide en
l'occident déserte
il occupe la place conclut le président
africain ainsi les quatre hommes d'état
semble bien d'accord ce n'est pas la
guerre
pas encore mais ce n'est plus la peine
et ce ne sont pas que des paroles chaque
jour nous amène son lot de conflit qui
révèle telle ou telle partie du globe
ainsi le yémen après l'assassinât du
chef de l'état du nord samedi
voilà que le sud est maintenant embrasé
mais il est difficile de voir la
relation directe entre les deux
événements ce que l'on sait c'est que ce
matin à aden la capitale du sud yémen de
violents troubles ont éclaté
il semble que l'on assiste un
soulèvement militaire contre le régime
prosoviétique en ce moment même
d'ailleurs les combats se poursuivent
toujours
et le président république a démissionné
il a été remplacé par son premier
ministre
ce que l'on sait aussi c'est que cette
région du monde est très convoité c'est
par là c'est là que passe tout le
pétrole en provenance des pays arabes
et c'est là au sud que les soviétiques
dont nous allons voir ici à un croiseur
avait en quelque sorte élu domicile
mais ce n'est que l'un des points chauds
d'une région explosive depuis toujours
le proche orient le proche-orient
premier relais du dossier que nous
allons ouvrir devant drapeaux israéliens
drapeaux égyptiens côte à côte à
jérusalem novembre 1977 il y à fait moi
avec la visite historique de sadate en
israël
sept mois avec des hauts et des bas sa
date samedi après-midi rejettent le plan
b jean visant à donner une autonomie
administrative à la cisjordanie béguines
hier rejetant le plan égyptien
visant à rendre la cisjordanie à la
jordanie est plus complexe encore les
problèmes intérieurs des israéliens avec
le général weissman ministre de la
défense numéro deux du gouvernement
en désaccord complet avec son premier
ministre béguines sur la politique à
suivre précisément sur cette portion de
territoire la cisjordanie aux questions
des américains béguines a répondu la
semaine dernière sans prendre position
rien ne sera réglé surtout pas le
problème des implantations en
cisjordanie
tant que la sécurité du territoire
israélien ne sera pas assurée par équipe
très attentif aussi les israéliens ne
laisserons pas la situation au sud liban
dégénéré ici aussi chaque jour chrétiens
palestiniens sont à deux doigts de
s'entretuer
reste enfin la volonté des américains de
carter le vice-président modèle sera tel
aviv la semaine prochaine avant une
étape au caire
ici ce sont les américains et russes
hull qui font ou défont la politique
depuis le départ des russes d'egypte
avec le contrôle sur les trois pays clés
de cette partie du monde qui sera l
egypte arabie saoudite et en jouant la
carte de l'équilibré des forces
on livrera des f-16 à israël mais aussi
dans le même temps à l'egypte contrôle
que pour des raisons stratégiques
les américains pourraient bien avoir
étendu jusqu'au yémen
voilà pour le proche-orient deuxième
région du monde très convoité l'afrique
tout alors encore le ministre cubain de
la belle rangée à reconnaissez à alger
que des soldats de son pays était en
voyant l'afrique à la demande des
gouvernements qui était en butte à une
intervention étrangère et monsieur mal
mira d'ajouter si l'ethiopie subi une
nouvelle agression nos troupes seront à
ses côtés et vous allez voir combien
l'afrique suscite d'appétit et de
convoitises tout commence en afrique un
beau jour de 1975 l'angola indépendante
la servir de tête de pont à la
pénétration soviétique sur le continent
noir
à partir de là la zambie la tanzanie
l'ethiopie le mozambique la libye entre
autres vont se ranger dans le camp
socialiste
c'est l'apparition des cubains en
afrique les cubains qui vont essayer de
réussir à 10000 km de la havane
ce qu'il n'avait pas pu réaliser en
amérique du sud jusqu'à présent les
américains assister en spectateur à l'
influence grandissante de l'union
soviétique en afrique or depuis quelques
jours washington tente de rattraper le
temps perdu
des conversations se sont ouvertes pour
la première fois entre américains et
angolais le président carter estime en
effet que l'angola pourrait devenir
paradoxalement le pays clé pour contrer
cette pénétration en face le camp pro
occidental qui pour des raisons autant
historique que politiques tentent de
s'organiser autour de la france la
décolonisation achevé paris a su en
effet gardé des liens étroits avec
toutes ses anciennes colonies africaines
ce sont précisément ces pays dits
modérés qui sont soumis actuellement à
ce que l'on appelle la déstabilisation
de l'afrique
à commencer par le tchad ou le zaïre
rébellions intérieures ou agressions
extérieures suivi d'un appel à l'europe
à chaque fois le scénario est le même à
chaque fois c'est la sécurité du
continent africain qui remise en
question à chaque fois ce sont des
foyers de tension qui s'allument mettant
en péril cette fameuse détente
enfin dernier baril de poudre pardon
pour l'image d'un monde rend soubresauts
l'extrême orient
là c'est peu de dire que les grands le
doigt sur la détente
car de très nombreux conflit dégénère
depuis la victoire du communisme sur
toute la péninsule indochinoise
un bref rappel des zones d'influencé qui
s'exerce en asie et thaïlandais ont
réussi à ne pas prendre parti contre le
vietnam mis le rsa il pense tout de même
vers la chine le cambodge c'est l'année
de la chine et le cambodge est en guerre
contre le vietnam le laos voisins de la
chine est carrément sous le contrôle
d'un rythme amiens depuis trois ans
vientiane est donc proscrite
enfin le vietnam en conflit avec pékin
c'est le premier allié l'urss dans la
région des vietnamiens sont en guerre
contre le cambodge
les cambodgiens et les khmers rouges
filmé ici en noir et blanc il ya trois
ans juste après la libération de nos
mains
le cambodge est en ce moment le grand
point chaud d'asie la chine et l'urss
affronte ici indirectement partenaires
vietnamiens interposés j'habite magnin
sont à plusieurs reprises essayé de
déstabiliser le régime comme peine soit
en favorisant un coup d'état en leur
faveur
soit en envahissant les zones
frontalières cambodgienne si hanoï
réussi dans cette entreprise pékin
interviendrez directement pour soutenir
en allier ce qui entraînerait de facto
l'engagement de moscou
une guerre qui serait peut-être plus
importante mais oui que la guerre
américaine au vietnam
c'était il ya trois ans nos rythmes
amiens prenaient d'assaut le palais
présidentiel de seiko évite amiens se
réunifier et surtout l'armée
vietnamienne devenait en hommes et en
matériel une des plus importantes est
l'une des plus entraîner de la région
cette armée représenta danger potentiel
pour l'ensemble de l'asie le cambodge
thaïlande et cetera mais aussi un danger
pour la chine car les un million cinq
cent mille soldats vietnamiens peuvent
gêner considérablement pékin au sud
si la chine entre en conflit avec le rss
au nord le conflit jusqu'à présent n'est
pas rentré dans une phase active
mais tout de même des scènes étranges et
prémonitoire se sont produites à la
frontière de deux pays il ya un mois
regardez bien ces bateaux chargés
d'hommes et de femmes se font des
chinois expulsé du vietnam vers la chine
hanoi les accuse d'être des capitalistes
infiltrés ils en ont pas vraiment l'air
non c'est un prétexte une façon pour les
vietnamiens d'exaspérer le grand voisin
et c'est un autre risque de guerre il
faut le considérer voilà sans vouloir
crier à l'apocalypse on est bien obligé
de constater qu'il ya là une
multiplication de conflits qui pour
l'instant se juxtaposent et qui bien un
jour pourrait amener à la guerre tout
court
c'est pourquoi nous avons sollicité la
réflexion de là les hommes depuis
passionné par les rapports est-ouest
vraiment les soviétiques sont devenue
activiste en afrique
à la faveur des circonstances qui se
présente par exemple l'afrique du sud
qu'ils peuvent combattre plus activement
que nous parce que nous occidentaux nous
blâmons le régime de l'afrique du sud
mais nous ne pouvons pas combattre
l'afrique du sud de la même manière que
le soulier union soviétique le fait
jaillir bon c'est un épisode la corne
d'afrique
ce mali ethiopie c'est à nouveau des
épisodes mais des épisodes significatifs
parce que stratégiquement
géostratégiquement c'est une position
d'une extrême importance et enfin
l'union soviétique en acceptant volant
140000 cubain en afrique a dans une
certaine mesure violé le code non écrits
de la descend de la détente au tout au
moins on était ils ont été plus loin que
jusqu'à présent nous sommes dans une
période de tension accrue ou un peu
partout il ya des points chauds et comme
ces points chauds se manifeste au même
moment
on y lit à une création d'atmosphères de
guerre mais je crois qu'il faut
conserver le la froideur le sang froid
en somme nous serions maintenant au
creux de la vague internationale est un
peu de beau temps pour demain je dirais
un peu le contraire nous sommes heureux
au sommet au sommet de la tension qui
révèlent la réalité de la situation
accident ce matin d'un décennale sur
l'aéroport de toronto 3 morts et une
cinquantaine de blessés dans l'appareil
qui s'est abîmé en bout de piste de
hold-up fructueux à paris aujourd'hui le
premier peu banal ce matin au ministère
des affaires sociales
cinquante cinq cent vingt ans a fait 52
millions de centimes vers au départ à 3
ans terre sous la menace d'une
mitraillette et d'un policier
le second s'est passé en début d'après
midi à l'hôtel ritz là encore trois
gangsters armés d'un revolver se sont
emparés de quatre cent mille francs le
reste d'une nouvelle de la journée
maintenant en bref et en images
vingt-quatre heures après l'explosion
accidentelle près de saint-dié du
gazoduc alimentant tout l'est de la
france la circulation du gaz a été
rétabli il ya plus de deux heures
les travaux effectués à proximité pour
doubler la conduite pourrait être à
l'origine de la rupture de la
canalisation
mais seule une enquête permettra d'en
connaître les causes exactes
aucune victime n'est à déplorer
l'explosion s'est passé dimanche soir en
pleine campagne à trois cents mètres de
toute habitation
la chasse à la baleine ne sera pas
interdite c'est ce que vient de décider
la commission internationale de la
baleine réunis à londres
la proposition du panama de cesser toute
capture pendant dix ans a été annulé sur
pressions économiques du japon
dans le même temps le navire du
mouvement écologiste greenpeace tente
dans les eaux islandaises de s'opposer
aux baleiniers russes et japonais
à bord une équipe d'antenne 2 qui
proposera prochainement un reportage
coup d'envoi aujourd'hui du tournoi de
wimbledon le sait doit chambers tenant
du titre depuis deux ans s'est
difficilement qualifié en cinq sets
devant l'américain a maille à un géant
de 2 mètres 0-2 borg demeure néanmoins
favori de ce tournoi
et s'il gagne il égalera le record de
fred perry
trois fois vainqueur à wimbledon
retransmission sur antenne de la semaine
prochaine de la suite du tournoi avec
les commentaires de roger couderc hervé
dudus et puis en cyclisme maintenant
avec à mes côtés par un effet de trucage
d'aia mois le tout nouveau champion de
france cette victoire bernard hinault
récompense le meilleur coureur d'une
épreuve mais aussi le plus régulier
alors en quelque sorte on peut dire que
c'est le prix d'assiduité pour une très
bonne saison pour vous alors on attend
maintenant prix d'excellence c'est à
dire pour le tour de france qui démarre
jeudi c'est le moral oui et de flat
toujours le moral quand on sait que ces
fins quand même un certain temps qu'on
le prépare et je crois qu'il faut avoir
vraiment le moral aussi pour le faire
bon tu sais quand même assez difficile
vous avez un petit accident que vous
confiez tout à l'heure à bernard robert
chapatte vous disiez que vous avez vu la
fringale qu'est ce que c'est la gamme en
termes ceux qui sont nés la fringale 7
lire c'est pas voir sa fille c'est
vraiment avoir faim et peep a procédé
tout à s'alimenter seulement voit les
trous noirs
je vous prie pour un appui james brown
revient en france à varier ses poulains
fois que ça m'arrive oui j'ai bien cru
que j'avais jamais passé assez mauvais
pour le tour ça non non parce que c'est
comme quelque chose qui m'est arrivé une
fois mais je crois que ça n'arrivera pas
deuxième fois dans quel sens vos
concurrents les plus dangereux est pour
cet or qu'il ai marre je dis bah il faut
voir quand même pollentier cuyper
thévenet bon mais on ne sait pas où il
en est puisqu'il a encore abandonné hier
au tour de france pour l'instant c'est
pas la bonne forme mais il lui reste
quand même dix jours pour se préparer et
peut-être qui sera là quand même temps
moyen laurent
peut-être essayer de rivaliser aussi et
puis autrement je vois pas van impe ou
madeleine il ya une clavicule cassée
donc sera divisé d'arrivée autrement il
y en a pas d'eau chaude
est ce qu'un coureur comme vous qui est
donné favori et maintenant un plan de
tours
non je crois que sur ce tour il faut
improviser
c'est au jour le jour il faut voir comme
l'état de fraîcheur de tous les coins
puis un jour attaque et oui un jour se
reposer c'est l'un ou l'autre mais
j'espère qu'on va vous retrouver dans un
mois habillé de jaune la télévision à
l'honneur avec la nomination du
réalisateur raoul sangla qui avait
inventé ce décor à la direction de la
maison de la culture de nanterre à
quelques jours des grandes vacances une
initiative de télé 7 jours la carte de
vie c'est une véritable carte d'identité
santé en cas d'accident vous la
trouverez aussi dans divers centres de
la croix rouge ainsi qu'une brochure
d'initiative d'initiation aux premiers
secours quelques gestes qui sauvent et
puis un anniversaire les 20 ans
d'intervalle route le service
d'information et de conseil routier
patronné par radio france
la météo maintenant et tout d'abord le
temps de ce lundi 26 juin variable et
frais sur la plus grande partie du pays
et surtout vous l'avez constaté des
températures bien basses pour la saison
il ya demain devrait être meilleur avec
davantage de soleil et une remontée de
température mais il y aura encore de
nombreux nuages notamment dans l'est et
le nord-est et peut-être même encore
quelques averses
22h40 c'est l'heure de votre dernier
rendez-vous avec l'actualité c'est
gérard holtz qui vous présentera ce
journal ainsi s'achève cette édition de
20h au long de toute l'équipe et de
toute la rédaction d'antenne 2 qui m'a
aidé à la composent et vous souhaite une
excellente soirée les coûts de nos
programmes au revoir à tous
à demain